- Hey guys. This is a quick
public service announcement
before my interview with David Horowitz.
David Horowitz actually
said a couple lines
that we are being forced to censor
because of the YouTube rules.
We have never done
something like this before
and as far as I know, David
Horowitz is a free citizen
in the free country of the United States
who is entitled to free speech.
That being said,
I can't risk having this
channel deleted from YouTube
and that basically is what would happen
if we went ahead and aired it unedited.
So, you will hear some
bleeps in this interview.
If you would like to
hear what David Horowitz,
a free man in the free
country, actually said,
you can check out the full
video at rubinreport.locals.com
Quick shoutout to Susan
Wojcicki over at YouTube.
(tongue clicking)
- People go along with
the crowd, it's survival.
It's very, when I was 35 and left the left
I lost every friend that I had in life.
I had to start all over again.
When that happened it seemed impossible.
But I've had a good life
afterwards, so it's possible.
But I think most people
are just afraid of losing their friends.
That's pretty much...
And that's why the left is so vicious
in the way it characterizes its opponents.
Because of that it
keeps everybody in line.
They don't want to be called racist
and white supremacist and all that.
(intro music)
I'm Dave Rubin and
joining is the original,
why I left the left guy
as well as the author of around 20 books.
I couldn't even figure out how many.
Including his most recent,
The Enemy Within: How
a Totalitarian Movement
is Destroying America.
David Horowitz, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks for having me, Dave.
- Glad to have you back on.
So first off, you've
written at least 20 books.
I mean, do you even know at this point?
- No. I actually don't.
But it's like that.
I've written like four
in the last two years.
- Yeah. You are a prolific writer.
I have many of your books on my shelf.
But let's quickly, before
we get into the new book,
and you've predicted, I mean,
you really have been right
about so much.
And I wonder if that makes
you feel good or depressed.
But before I do anything else,
you sort of are the original,
why I left the left guy.
For people that haven't
seen our original interview,
we'll link to it down below.
But you sort of 30 years
before me, made that move.
I suspect you feel pretty good about it
after coming from a family that
was communist and socialist
and being a lefties and then
finally Reagan broke ya.
And here ya are.
- It's hard to feel good
about being right about
such terrible things that
have happened to our country.
Yeah, I was raised by communists.
I was the editor of the largest
magazine in the new left.
And I left the left when I
realized, as you did eventually,
that it's not about peace and justice.
It's a hate America left.
These people are, they're totalitarians.
They want to control
every aspect of your life
down to the pronouns.
And that makes them very, very dangerous.
It's a crypto religion, as
I've said for a long time.
They believe in a redemption
but they think the redeemers
can be politicians.
Please. There can never
be a world that's just
because it's made up of
people who are the problem.
It's the perception of...
The whole, our whole saga is
told in genesis in the bible
A had paradise was better
than the green new deal
but there was only one thing you had to do
to stay in paradise
and that was not to want to do evil.
It's mind boggling to me because of the..
You have all this live television,
these television shows about murders,
about how terrible people are.
If they just showed you
the cruelty to animals
that people are capable
of, you could never believe
in a world redeemed by
radicals or any mortals.
- Yeah, well I suspect that the mortals
on the cover of this book
are not the mortals that you
think are going to get us
to redemption. I mean this is a...
This is pretty much all of
the bad guys right here.
- That's the favorite part of
my contribution to the book.
I designed that cover.
- There you go. You designed
the cover with the head shots,
with the head shots of some radicals.
Do you believe, is it your position,
that they all are equally radical?
Like is the Ilhan Omar, say AOC,
Ayanna Pressley thing,
or Rashida Tlaib thing,
is that as, is it that more radical
than say, Pelosi, Shumer, Biden
or is it all just the
same thing at this point?
- The thing in the left and that
is there are very few serious people.
We're living on so much
misinformation and ignorance,
so I think people go along
with the crowd, it's survival.
It's very...
When I was 35 and left the left,
I lost every friend that I had in life
and I had to start all over again.
When that happened, it seemed impossible.
But I've had a good life
afterwards, so it's possible.
But I think most people are just afraid
of losing their friends.
That's pretty much...
And that's why the left is so vicious
in the way it characterizes its opponents.
Because of that it
keeps everybody in line.
They don't want to be called racist
and white supremacist and all that.
I think we're, the sad reality
is that we're in the early
stages of fascist state,
and I use that word advisedly.
If you think of the...
I just lost a friend of
70 years, Ron (indistinct)
I actually wrote a story about it.
Because I questioned the
election results in 2020,
I lose a friend of 70 years?
When there's all of these
irregularities that are obvious.
And when nobody has done
an audit of the election
and when the democrats have challenged
every republican presidential victory
since 2000,
2000, 2004,
and of course, the Trump election.
And then if you look what
happened on January 6th,
this is the great crime of conservatives.
First of all, Trump's speech basically...
Not basically, literally
in so many words he said,
"I want you to protest
peacefully and patriotically,
I want you to stiffen the
spines of weak republicans
who are afraid to challenge
this election result,
and if you fail," he said,
"then what you must do
is go home and primary them."
You can't imagine a more
democratic, peaceful
statement than that.
Okay, so those people went
and for whatever reason,
some of them got out of control
and the crime they've been charged,
actually charged with, is trespassing.
There are people who are still in jail.
It's now five months, held without bail
for trespassing.
And what was the democrats reaction?
They called it an armed insurrection
even though there was not
a single arm confiscated.
- Zero, zero.
- It was actually a
fairly peaceful protest
when you think about
everything that happened
all summer with democrat support.
They didn't burn the capital,
they didn't destroy a lot of things
and the only person who was
murdered, that was killed,
was a Trump supporter.
And her murderer is protected by Pelosi.
We still don't know his
name and he's not...
There are not going to be any charges.
And it was videoed by a journalist
who's showing that she was
completely non threatening.
She was unarmed, she's small
and she was threatening nobody
when she was killed.
That journalist, Hispanic, is in jail
for being there and being a journalist.
If this isn't fascism,
I don't know what is.
But it's worse than that because Pelosi,
remember she said republicans
are enemies of the state.
And remember the democrats, the leftest,
the far left of the democrat,
which is a pretty dominant (indistinct)
called for the expulsion,
actually of 100 republicans
from the house for
questioning the election.
Josh Hawley and Ted Cruz were singled out
by the democrat leadership
to be removed from the senate
because they questioned an election.
When the democrats have
done this every election
in recent memory.
- Hilary Clinton still
has a tweet up right now
about the illegitimate
presidency of Donald Trump
- Yeah, exactly. They
never accepted Trump.
Yet, this is supposed to be a threat
to our democracy that you raise.
And anybody who's looked
at the evidence knows
that there were humongous irregularities,
to put a nice term on
it, during the election.
But then Nancy Pelosi orders 25,000 troops
into the capital at a cost
of half a billion dollars
for a nonexistent, non specified threat.
What is that but to send
a message to conservatives
that they're gunning for us?
Then the head of the military
orders a two month stand down
to conduct a witch hunt
of so called extremists
in the military, then
in the capital police,
then in the homeland security.
Then the justice department
announces there's...
Going to allocate $89 million
to investigate extremists,
I mean, conservatives
all over the country.
It's so reminiscent of the Reichstag fire.
Hitler was elected in a
democracy, the Weimar republic.
He was elected chancellor.
He gets into power and the
first thing the Nazis do
is they burn down their own
capital, called the Reichstag,
blame it on a Dutch communist
and pass a Reichstag fire
act to criminalize descent,
which is what the
democrats have been doing
ever since Donald Trump was elected.
Criminalize descent and
established the Third Reich.
You know what? One thing that my book,
The Enemy Within does, is I document,
if you look at the democrat's agenda
it's not about getting rid of Trump,
it's not about winning an election,
it's about establishing a one party state.
Stack the Supreme Court,
that's to abolish the
independent judiciary.
Abolish the electoral college,
which was designed to force
presidential candidates
to compete in ballot round states
where they didn't have a majority,
thus force them to
compromise our whole system,
is built on compromise.
That's why we've only have one civil war
and no successful coup d'etat.
The democrat program is a fascist program.
There is nobody...
The only republicans who are legitimate
are those, you know like Liz Cheney.
- Right, they love Liz Cheney
now because she's a pet.
So, you lay all of this out in the book.
It's quite extraordinary
actually, and as I said,
you've been right about a lot of stuff
way before a lot of people.
So what do you think the
average conservative,
and I now use that term in a broad sense.
If you believe America is good,
you're a conservative
as far as I'm concerned.
What do you think the average conservative
can do to fight this
because it feels like the deck is
completely stacked against us?
- Republican conservatives
have been asleep for 50 years
while the democrats have
taken over our culture.
I wrote five books on the universities,
that of one of them people
paid a little attention to.
But the republican...
And I organized academic freedom campaigns
and I got no real support
out of the republican party.
But between Obama and, I
all him the (indistinct)
and Biden, one of the nastiest
human beings on the planet.
I don't know how he gets this reputation
for being a nice guy.
They've begun to wake people up.
And Donald Trump has given our country
and patriots a great gift.
And this is, he has created the first
mass conservative movement in our history.
When I came into the right in the mid 80s,
40 years ago now,
I looked around and said,
"Where's the ground army?"
And all my ex comrades
on the left are at awe.
They had 100 organizations, or 200,
to harass, and threaten, and defame
politicians until they got on their...
Into their program and corporations.
Why are corporations involved?
Corporations are basically cowards.
They don't want to lose customers,
that's their bottom line.
But if you harass them
enough, they will respond.
And it's interesting already,
the backlash has caused them
Disney just pulled back
its racist program.
I long to see people get in the face
of teachers, of principals,
of superintendents,
of schools, of school boards
who are indoctrinating their children
and hate America, garbage.
And you know, we're so backward,
I've been watching FOX
and they're talking about
the 1619 project, and they're
talking about the 20 slaves.
There weren't slaves.
I mean, I've read Neil Painter,
who's a black leftist Princeton historian
on this subject. They
were indentured servants.
And slavery was actually
outlawed Virginia in 1619.
And Virginia wasn't America in 1619.
It was a British colony.
And this is supposed to be our founding
according to these liars,
and yet if you look at
FOX, they're not saying...
They don't know the facts.
- Right. To be clear, we were not a nation
till about 150 years later.
So, the idea that the nation was founded
on something that happened 150 before,
when everyone was dead,
seemed a little odd.
- Just terrible.
- So, what does the future...
- I want to see a sit in at
the headquarters of Twitter
announcing their censorship,
embarrassing them.
That's what's really needed.
And I see the stirrings
of it all over the place.
There are people organize...
Particularly, in the schools
and that gives me hope.
- Do you think though that,
since you brought up Twitter,
that the big tech part of this
is the part that makes the
asymmetry so out of wack?
It would be one thing if it
was slightly out of wack,
but now, the way we get
information is so tilted
that people can't coordinate properly
or can't even get the information properly
or agree on what's true.
- Change is coming.
The one thing about tech
is it's always changing.
What's it called? Sub stack,
already is a media outlet
that has a lot of people who are
second thoughters like you on it,
people who have impeccable
leftist credentials
who are really upset
about the cancel culture.
And just the terms we use; cancel culture.
It's book burning, it's what
the Nazi's did in the 30s
You can't just burn books today
because you've got a digital
universe that you can't burn.
But that's what it is
and I would like to see people,
I mean, I know that I'm
not making myself popular
by referring to the Biden
administration as fascist,
but technically, that's what it is.
And I tell you, if we don't stop them,
they will put us in reeducation camps.
They've already telegraphed that.
That conservatives are
(indistinct) racists
who have to be reprogrammed.
- You think, do we get to share
a gulag as the YLFLF guys?
That would be nice.
- That's very probable.
- Very probable, great.
- (indistinct)
and that book really moved me at the time.
- Yeah, well, you know I
toured with Jordan Peterson
and he often brought up the Gulag Acapella
for the same reason .
- Thank my lucky stars
for Jordan Peterson.
Otherwise I would be feeling guilty
about all the things I wasn't writing.
one part I would like to mention
is the chapter on, or
chapters on the black list
very, very serious.
I'm not going to name the
outlet but I wrote this article
about how Ron (indistinct)
had joined the fascists
and slipped a knife between my ribs.
- I've got the piece right here.
- I tried to place it with a
very prominent conservative
media site but they're also on Facebook.
You know, if you're a big media site,
you got to be on all the platforms.
And they said that Facebook
would just close it down
if it appeared there.
People have to understand,
we are in the early stages
of a fascist state. We do not...
America is no longer a free country.
Its freedom is hard won by
courageous people like yourself
who are willing to stand up
and take the slings and arrows.
- So what do we do then?
We can sit in at Twitter.
I know you're a fighter.
You've been doing this for a long time.
What do we really do?
Is Trump the only thing that can save us?
Do we need the return of
Trump to lead the republicans?
It ain't going to be Liz Cheney.
- Here's what I think about Trump.
People are talking about
Ron DeSantis, whom I admire,
and in my black list
story, I tell how they used
First, they called me a notorious racist,
then because he spoke at
my events, they used that,
and when I say they,
I'm talking about the
so called liberal media,
New York Magazine, Washington Post,
used that to try to taint
him and destroy him.
And he has a delivery
which a lot of people think
is more user friendly,
shall we say than Trump's
and I hope he's on the ticket, actually.
But the reason that I
believe that Trump is
bound to be the leader, is
(bleep)
He got 75 million votes,
despite four years
of unbelievable slander
and lies direct to him
and no credit for what he had done.
But I think ordinary
Americans, patriotic Americans,
see this guy as someone,
here he was, a billionaire
living the life and he
put himself and his family
through all this to save
the country, basically.
I mean, those credentials are golden
you really can't beat them.
And I think his aggression is necessary.
The reason the democrats hate him
is because he called them out.
Called them out as racist
for their control of the inner cities.
Called them out for
their betrayal of the...
I will say, as somebody who's
been in politics 50, 60 years,
I had no idea that they
were selling us out
in trade deals the way they were.
I mean, it's Bush, Clinton, Obama.
Either they were too lazy to
cut decent deals for Americans
or they just didn't care
about fleecing our country
for Chinese communists,
they're genocidal dictators,
for crying out tears.
- Do you think that
that's what it really is?
That in many ways, just we've gone through
several generations at this point,
or at least several decades,
of just leadership and
an institutional elite
that has sold us out at every level
so there almost isn't enough
of what is American left
to defend the documents
that freed all of us?
- Well, we have to have
a leader who fights
and that's Trump.
What American would blow
up the Southern border
in the middle of a global pandemic
with new viruses or
variants, as they call them
are appearing all the time?
Biden has just let 100,000 COVID carriers
into the country, which
shows what a liar he is
every time he's accused Trump of killing
corona virus patients.
He's killing them, he's killing Americans.
The child abuse epic on the border.
It's just unreal, and
the denial of reality..
This is the norm. It's not the norm.
It's like 20 times whatever...
I forget the actual statistics.
But they're humongous in terms of the
deterioration of the country.
The amount of criminals
who are being left in,
the amount of people who
have not pledged allegiance
to our society. America is unique.
It's our culture, something
leftists never understand.
Culture determines things.
How is it that Japan, which
has no natural resources,
is a first world country?
Mexico, which has oil,
which has had it's independence
for 100 years or whatever,
is flooding refugees into America.
What's the difference
between Japan and Mexico?
It's all about culture,
and America had a great culture
which is being systemically
dismantled by the democrats.
- So, as someone that
gets this, and as I said
you've been right on so
much of this way earlier
but you're still now,
you're losing friends
that are, that you've had for 70 years.
People ask me this,
maybe you have a better
answer than I have.
If someone's kind of wavering right now
and they're kind of waking
up to some of this stuff,
because I think a lot of people are.
I think people are shocked at how horrific
the Biden administration has been
and how out of control wokeism is.
What's the move that you've made
to really help people wake up?
Beyond just handing
them facts, I mean that,
we know that that doesn't always work.
- I mean, this book has a
lot about the race issue
and the way they deploy
racism and sexism as weapons.
I think the biggest thing is
if somebody is truly in transition,
it means they're reading and thinking
or listening and thinking.
My friend, or former friend (indistinct).
It's been three years,
I could not ever get him
I would write an email and we
had all kinds of ground rules
to protect our egos or what have you.
Couldn't get him to
consider a single argument.
I said in my book, I'm (indistinct)
I said in the manuscript of
this book, The Enemy Within
and in the article that Ian Stern wrote
for the new republic,
there's no a singe argument
that I give that's engaged.
(bleep)
- You're trying to get
me booted from YouTube.
- I try to think about those things.
I try never to get people into situations
that they can't handle, but I
know that you can handle it.
- Thanks David.
- I can't clip my wings.
- Fair enough. I don't bring
you on to clip your wings.
And I'll deal with those guys.
- Everything rests on
creating or energizing
this mass movement and
directing it to protest this.
Taking back the congress,
dealing with the tech companies.
Trump was in power for four years.
It's like republicans said for a decade,
they said they're going
to repeal and replace
Obama care and they never did.
That's the huge...
Conservatives are always
complaining about the media,
which is fair. It's a
lying, disgusting media.
I'm racist, seeing CNN.
They're just filled with liars
and racists, and not to mention MSNBC.
But the real problem is the
politeness of conservatives.
Conservatives are being
called white supremacists,
white nationalists, traitors,
enemies of the state,
insurrections actually.
And what do republicans
call democrats? Liberals.
(Rubin laughs)
- We can't win that war.
We're the only liberals
and the only people in this
country who want to hear
two sides to a conversation
are conservatives.
And you know that all you
have to do is turn on FOX
Or News Max, the conservative media,
They're always entertaining the other side
because I think
conservatives are confident
we can win the arguments,
we're not afraid of them.
And if we're wrong, we're capable
of changing our views on a subject.
- David, defending my liberal beliefs
has become a conservative position.
It's always a pleasure talking to you
because I love the fact that people,
people did this before me and
people will do this after me
and I appreciate all the fight, and I...
You fled California, so you left me here.
So I hope to see you one of these days
but I'm guessing it's not
because you're coming back here.
- No, you'll be on your way to Florida
or some other (indistinct) Texas
and you can stop on the way and visit me.
- The book is Enemy Within.
Thank you so much, David.
- We'll see each other
again on your podcast
because I got another book
coming out in the fall
- Naturally. I will gladly have you on.
Thank you, my friend.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.